sausage party even though their hotdogs
is the new rated our animated raunchy
comedy from the director of Madagascar 3
Shrek 2 and monster vs. aliens combine
with the visionary filmmaker behind a
shit-ton of Thomas the Tank Engine this
is a bit of a departure from that shit
this movie tells the story of a bunch of
food all these characters live in a
supermarket you got hot dogs you got
buns you have tacos ketchup mustard
lettuce you get it all of this food
resides and lives at a supermarket and
they are under the belief system that
human beings are gods and when you are
chosen and placed in that shopping cart
you are going to heaven a place that's
magical but as we know that's not quite
how it goes down and their entire belief
system crumbles and when one character
learns this he feels very compelled to
warn all of his friends of this now this
movie is extremely satirical this movie
isn't so much the laugh riot that the
trailers are making it out to be this is
far more of a satirical look at our
world belief in God politics warring
countries that are portrayed as various
foodstuffs yes this is a little bit more
of a brainy film than I expected well
also having my god an absurd amount of
Raj holy shit this movies rated R it's
gonna be a long time before I eat any
bagels some stuff goes down towards the
end of this film that is insane my jaw
was on the floor the concept of this
movie is great that's one of my favorite
things about it it definitely pokes fun
at Disney movies showing something that
we're used to as people and the secret
life that it has you know that's a
common thing in Disney films and this
movie definitely takes that that puts it
through a blender and you get an adult
animated film that is very funny at
times they actually cursed so much in
this movie that it got old after a while
it got to a point where I was like this
isn't really funny anymore I get that a
hot dog saying fuck is funny but after
two hundred times or the same type of
joke it did get old after a while the
movie isn't as consistently entertaining
as I was hoping it was going to be I
loved the concept and once you actually
do see the food realizing what her
purpose in life is that's really funny
and the trailer promises that and it's
not so much about that it actually
spends a lot more time at
Supermarket which was disappointing to
me some of the jokes do fall flat
kristen wiig as this bun that just
really wants seth rogen to put his hot
dog in there that's the honest truth I'm
not making it up that's the that's it
I like Kristen Wiig sometimes she was
really funny but there was this whole
thing where she would sing she wanted to
say something was maybe slightly
embarrassing so she would just sing it
instead and didn't always work for me
this movie is entertaining enough and
you can watch it as a raunchy r-rated
animated film but I think it relies too
much on the whole novelty that we are
watching an r-rated animated movie and I
think for me somebody who's watched a
lot of anime that's very violent and
I've seen a lot of things in animation
form it doesn't really have that shock
value for me anymore because I am more
exposed to more adult forms of animation
through things like anime and so when I
watch this movie it doesn't really have
that weight or that impact that I think
they were going for it is a bit hit or
miss but still in the end I had fun with
this movie simply on the concept alone
and I'm going to give sausage party of B
- guys I have a lot of reviews to do our
stuff Pete's dragon and blood father
coming look forward to those you guys
are the best thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes